[Music]
welcome to the AI the future of us a
podcast Style video says that explores
the ways AI is shaping our future and
how we can prepare for the changes that
layer had I am your host ferrat sakinar
and today we are joined by sirian
Peterson who is a data and ml specialist
here at Google Cloud
before being here today sir
I know that we both started our Journeys
in Academia with our phds but in
different ways and eventually ended up
being data and AI professionals and we
have been doing this for a while but
with that can you also tell to the
audience here below about your
background and expertise in the field of
AI
show them so think about thank you for
the invitation peanut I started out as a
data scientist business analyst at
Google and during that time I already
worked on machine learning specific
projects mostly focused on natural
language processing like text
classification
after that I moved to Google cloud and
there I started to work as a machine
learning specialist and in this role I
advise companies on AI and large-scale
data and AI infrastructure
how did you become interested in AI
though and you know what do you what do
you find the most fascinating about AI
well I was always fascinated that data
traditional statistics and then later AI
allows us to see a different
representation of the world so take
embeddings for example
um with machine learning we are able to
represent unstructured data such as text
numerically in a lower dimensional space
and this allows us for example to
understand that one sentence similar to
another sentence and I always found this
interesting to have like a different
view of the world
yeah it's interesting right that how the
traditional statistics really you know
still works very close with AI and
everything that we do and could you
share some of it
the eye developments that you know you
witnessed during your career and the
things that really you know stuck stuck
with you as well
true from a research point of view I
think the introduction of the
Transformer architecture in 2017 with
the similar paper attentions all you
need was a turning point and it
basically paved all the way for large
language models as we know them today
um the second thing is that the
increasing relevance of machine learning
operations or ml Ops as we call up
when I started my current role
approximately five years ago a large
part of companies were still like
tinkering with machine learning they
were doing pocs and they were trying out
what's helped machine learning had to
offer nevertheless we did not see many
machine learning projects in production
during that time
this has changed tremendously over the
years and the productionization of
machine learning has become way more
prominent like Frameworks like
kubernetes or computer pipelines rosin
prominence and some other when some of
the discussions have shifted away from
like how do I train a model which is
still important to more or like a
different kind of discussions like how
do I build a scalable model registry or
how do I automate my test process
and the third thing that I have uh also
that also has changed is that they shift
from creating your own models from
scratch towards transfer learning for
traditional architectures and nowadays
using fine-tuning and chrome tuning for
large models and large language models
in particular
that's interesting right then how much
we have come true in particular from you
know attention is all you need that
everyone is talking around the attention
and the context of you know the language
in a sense I remember the days that I
used to work at the in a natural Center
for text mining when I was in Academia
15 years ago and we didn't have any of
that it was really hard even in Academia
to get this running it's interesting you
know it's interesting that you know we
are observing that as well but one of
the other things that I always seen
throughout my career is that there's
always the scap between data and the
Machine learning whether you are a data
analytics you know professional or a
data engineer or whether you are machine
learning engineer a data scientist and
according to you what are the main
overlaps that you see for traditional to
separate disciplines that you know we
see in the industry a lot we operate a
little bit differently but you know
that's what we see outside a lot as well
how do you think that you know it how it
overlaps
um sure so I think the first one and the
most obvious ones that both built on
robust data are like both need to have
like a real estate ecosystem and for
most of the tasks the data that you have
the quality of the data and its
accessibility
um Define the success of every
Downstream processes that you are
building up and it doesn't matter if
like you're building or if you're
retraining there are one billion
parameter large favor tomorrow or if you
try to generate statistical inference
using obvious regression data quality
and control our crucial the second part
I see is that and this is my personal
observation is that engineering best
practices and machine also machine
learning best practices have become more
relevant for traditional data analytics
and this means like using Version
Control or writing text tests this might
have like several reasons but one of the
reasons might be that in particular in
smaller companies data analysts or
analysts in general need to wear several
hats and one of these heads might be or
is for example the head of the data
engineer and the third point is that I
believe that python has become the de
facto standard in data analytics but
also machine learning and having a
Common Language between the different
fields between data analytics between
machine learning and data engineering
really has helped that those three
Fields have grown together milk calcium
yes it's interesting right and we are
also saying that with the you know with
the llms and the generator AI we are
seeing more and more they're coming
together so we are seeing more overlap
and the you know two distinct
environments are coming together more
and more because it is allowing and it
is uplifting the users as well and
that's some of the things that I'll come
back and ask you in a minute but before
I get there you know the challenges that
we see with the separation of these two
organizations it's also challenging to
get into production systems right you
know and it has taken that we are using
all of this but it is a different matter
to bring it into production first we
need to sort out the as you said the
data and the data ecosystem we need to
have all the you know data governance
practice in place as well so with that
how do you see the data Ops and mlops
with llms in mind involving within the
next few years
shown so
um the uh the overall answer is that
data and emeralds will become more
relevant
um
um a stress them as we addressed it
already in the previous question like a
successful data and machine Learning
Systems rest on a on like analytics and
machine learning systems do rest on a
solid data ecosystem to be a little bit
more specific
um quite often like when we when we work
with llms they seem to be like magical
so they walk about data and you do not
need to train them because they come
pre-trained and then they can do
something
um nevertheless for a significant part
of use cases language models and large
models or large range models need to be
aligned with the user's intent and be a
term of alignment will come like we will
touch upon this term and guess in the
next questions
um but in order to align those models
with the users intends their large
language models and language models and
large models need to be tuned and to do
so you need to have like good data
quality so data quantity is promoting
the second thing is that
um a large part of machine learning
operation deals with model performance
and explainability
so you want to know is the model doing
what it should do and then you also want
to know like why is the model what is it
for what what the model is doing so how
does it reach its conclusions and um
llms have the tendency to be a little
bit more opaque compared to traditional
machine learning models and this is why
machine learning operations and ml Ops
is so important because
um you have this expendability part and
you also have this model performance
part and this is where you need to put
an external special emphasis when you
talk about large language and the third
part is that we always need to Envision
machine learning models being part of a
larger technical landscape because quite
often when we when we discuss machine
learning and we just focus on the
machine learning model but those models
are always embedded in a lot of
technical landscape
and in this case we talk about machine
learning systems and if we assume now
that the data complexity is increasing
that we have to deal with more data in
the future but that also the opaqueness
of the model or the complexity of the
models is increasing
um what we will see then is that and
this is the direct direct result of
those two trends that
data operations but also machine
learning operations will become way more
relevant in the future
I totally agree with you and I think
we'll be seeing more and more that the
data governance and the ml governance is
coming together because your your ml is
really as good as your date site then
not today right so this the Harvard
Business to your article still Stacks
with me that the headline was uh your AI
applications will be as good as your
data analytics applications and that's
really correct and we have been doing
you know machine learning for a long
time there are many applications in many
industries that are used on a daily
basis as well however with llms we are
now making this more mainstream given
that the way that they work that they
really bridge the gap you know and how
do you see these challenges you know
applying and using generative AI in
particular
um so the challenges
um when using generative AI so first of
all first and foremost I guess the
biggest uh challenges that we need to
take as I said before we need to take a
step back and think about let me think
about large language models and
generative AI is being part of a larger
machine Learning System so thinking from
data extraction to data processing to
the model training to the model serving
and generative AI or large language
models have definitely added some
additional challenges for for in certain
areas for example in terms of
explainability as we have discussed
before but also in terms of training
um but I guess the the core challenge
has remained the same in terms of
machine learning because what we want to
do is like we want to build first of all
robust data ecosystem first and then we
want to build a robust end-to-end
machine learning systems and what we
have discussed before is like one of the
key challenges with large language
models is that they are opaque so we
need to put again like specific like
special emphasis on explainability and
performance which also increase fairness
and segment there's also a technical or
more engineering perspective because as
the name says like um the models are
pretty large so we need to think about
like how can we train them efficiently
and effectively and how can we not just
train them but also like how can we
serve them how can we make the serving
fast how we can make the serving cheap
those are the things that we need to
think about from more um engineering Ops
perspective sort of said
Akron there's lots of you know
discussion around that within the uh
within the AI and ml ecosystem I think
it is really a thing particularly how
you use the prompt whether you are using
you know specific Corpus for example for
the model that you are training whether
you are getting a specific outcome or
you are looking to get specific outcomes
it is really you know it is kind of like
multi-objective optimization problem how
much effort that you put in and how much
value that you get out from the business
side of things you know really but what
are the examples that you know you are
saying with Gen AI use in the you know
industry you know and what are the
things that you have been saying
of course
um so I'm I'm working a lot in the
retail industry and so far what we can
say is like we are still exploring all
the different possibilities because
there are so many things that you can
basically do with large men's wallets
um so to
um to maybe to start a little bit more
high level and to think about more
abstract about the core capabilities of
what those models can do there are three
main capabilities I would solve of
course there are more but for like for
this discussion let's think about three
things that they that those moments can
do very well one thing is search you can
search you can use those models for
example to search code to search
documents and this is a huge um
this is a this is a huge thing because
in a lot of companies there's a lot of
information available but this kind of
information is not accessible and
helping companies and internally as well
as externally accessing this information
with large language modes is very
important and so it's a great use case
the second thing is everything that is
related to content creation so you can
you can think about like using large
language models for creating code for
creating code descriptions you can use
it for operating images you can use it
for creating text and you can also use
it for creating metadata and so the
source is super interesting
um a quick example maybe
um I have a have a bottle here so um if
you're searching internally for a bottle
uh so your current metadata maybe just
says like this is bottle this is a
bottle of water however this is a glass
bottle
um and when I'm looking now for in my in
my system and I'm typing in the
following I want to have like a healthy
drink
um then it would not find this because
it doesn't have the metadata it doesn't
know that this is healthy but if I ask a
large language model for example like
what is a healthy drink it's quite
likely that we'll say like well water is
a healthy drink so what I can do is
basically by combining those
capabilities this general knowledge of
the word with for example the metadata
that I have I can do this I can like do
a search and then first our customers
can search my my catalog or I can only
conserve something and say like well
give me healthy drinks it gives me like
well maybe you try it maybe you try
water so this is the second thing the
second card
and then the third part of course is
everything in this conversational and so
classical chatbot and uh this is the uh
this is the the third big uh use case or
the area where we see a lot of potential
with large molds and large hanger spots
and it's interesting right because the
search has been using LMS in Google side
of things when you go to Google search
for you know for some time well as
you're typing it would give you that
context you know but I I also want to
see uh specifically for data analytics
what are the use cases that you are
saying you know and any any specific
things from the data attic side of
things yes of course so uh for data
analytics I think there will be a great
democratization of of analytics and it
will be way easier to interact with data
so let's assume uh the following you are
working at a retailer and you want to do
the following uh you you need to do you
need to write some SQL code
um or let's start differently you want
to have some information
um so you would like to have the
information
um I want to have the sales numbers for
product X for the last two years for
Countrywide so what you can do is you
can go to your database you can write
some SQL code and then you can write the
code obviously and then you get the
answer but maybe you're not so familiar
with with SQL so what you can do in
status you can use a large language
model and you can ask more what I want
to have this like please provide me the
sales numbers for product X for the last
two years for Country Y and then the
model will translate so to say you are
you are asking to SQL code and then you
might give it access to your to your
database and then we can return to the
results so this is the first thing in
term critization the second thing is
also which is also relevant is that you
can make data more accessible so assume
the following use case you are your
analyst and you get the request like we
want to understand like how customers
and how satisfied our customers with one
of our products so what you what would
normally do is like maybe you have like
customer ratings
so you would run analysis on customer
ratings but what if if you have a lot of
text so you have a lot of reviews and
you would like to Deep dive into those
reviews and like think about like 10
years ago or like five years ago even it
was not so easy to to handle this kind
of unstructured data so you needed to
have like a knowledge about like um you
know a natural language processing
um so it's It's Tricky it's not super
easy but what you can do today for
example is you can ask a large language
model look here's a review and this is
the review text and please read this
review text and give me an answer if
this review is a positive review and
into a review or if it's a non-positive
revenue and by doing so you can leverage
for example unstructured data this case
text Data very easily and this is the
second big
Trends or the second big benefit that I
see that you can make your data more
accessible and that you can leverage
different kinds of data in particular
unstructured data something which was
not so easy a few years ago
and that's interesting right where we
are you know getting really so we
discussed this that the democratization
is really key it is an overloaded word
but you know uh
on a program by trade you know and I I
put on so many things in life but I find
myself I go to bad and I ask for you
know the court Snippets and stuff before
I get access I I do anything now right
so it gives me really you know court
that works as well it is really
fascinating but also from the you know
the data analytics point of view uh it
is interesting to see what is it coming
whether you know I can use directly from
things like bigquery uh uh L alams by
calling vertex AI you know llamson I can
look into sentimental some unstructured
texts and stuff as well and with that
right what advice would you give to
individuals and businesses looking to
prepare for the future because you know
where AI plays even more significant
role in data analytics as we discussed
right is going to become more and more
upfront and you know everyone will be
you know it is touching everyone's
journey in a sense data Journey
yes that's a very good question so my my
answer is like a non some like a
non-technical non-ai answer and so the
first thing I think you should do is
like strengthen the domain specific
knowledge and when this is becoming
super important that you know a lot
about your domain because Ai and
analytics are tools helping you to
answer a question but it's up to you to
come up with a good question so
um unsurprisingly the quality of the
questions that you ask strongly
correlate with the quality of healing
domain knowledge so boom the very
important thing is that you have some
domain knowledge for example if you're
an analyst and get some domain knowledge
and if you if you're working in retail
um like get really domain models into
forecasting like what is like how does
it do forecasting processes look like
what what is it what does it mean to to
create it with forecast and then think
about like okay how can I leverage AI in
order to do better forecasting for
example so this is the first
and the second thing is that um when we
think about AI we often think about AI
in an incremental way so we have a
process or we have something and then
just put like AI on top but in
particular when you are
trying to achieve some non-incremental
change or some radical change with
processes you might think about like not
just treating Ai and also like for
analytics as an add-on but that you
really start to rethinking a business
process from scratch and really start
okay like how can I how can we really
rethink the whole process and the whole
thing starting with AI and not just like
having the process that it is yet and
just adding AI on top
yes and it's it's interesting right that
it I I agree with you that you still
need that knowledge also I want to you
know in order to get the value out of it
you should be able to understand the
feedback that you get from the you know
the machine as well but also uh your
creativity is going to play a
significant role in my opinion here
right because it is going to make you
more creative you'll be able to you know
get away from the repetitive tasks by
using you know llms in your day
day-to-day work and it will allow you to
be more creative it will also give you
more uh more tool set to you know
display and get your creativity out as
well and that also requires the
knowledge as you say and as we look
ahead and this is my last question to uh
siren as we look ahead to the Future AI
what do you believe are the most
critical areas of research and
development that still need to be you
know addressed as well
yes um so the uh I guess the because the
biggest topic is alignment uh we we
heard it before and Alignment basically
says what alignment means is like that
the model behaves in accordance with
what a human wants and uh there are a
lot of things that are that you know
that you need to do in order to create
this kind of a line and one thing
um so there are basically three things
but the first thing is that
um customization and fine-tuning because
just having a large language model is
often not enough so the model needs to
be tuned or fine-tuned according on your
domain specific or use case specific or
on a particular use case so there's a
lot of research right now on like how to
actually do the customization the best
way like using your own data I mean you
might have heard like terms like Chrome
tuning uh like fine-tuning or full
fine-tuning and Etc and there's a lot of
there's a lot of research going on right
now okay how do I actually customize or
fine-tune my model so that I can achieve
the results that I want to achieve the
second thing is that sustainability and
we have stressed this before we know we
want to know why does the model make a
certain insertion because only when we
know why a model is doing like why model
is doing a certain session we can then
analyze okay with this a good decision
was this a bad decision
um and finally we have engineering
challenges because as the name suggests
like Welsh language models are super
large and they have like very specific
requirements for training and serving
and um you need to think about like how
can we surf those models and how can
train those models
um very very efficiently and those are
three
um points major points I guess that all
like go like are all sub points of the
of this General topic of alignment like
how to make the models useful and how to
make them behave the way that the user
wants them to behave and this is where I
see a lot of research going on in the
future
yes and and I agree and we are seeing a
lot you know a lot of work happening in
this area uh it is interesting right
because uh Google has been doing this
for a long time we learned a lot we
applied all of this in our you know
systems and applications we publish our
you know thousand papers annually right
and I'll you know enables us to
collaborate and share ideas as well as
learn from the broader scientific
Community as well so and we'll we'll I
think we'll see more of that it will
allow us to you know be the leaders on
this as well thank you for joining us
today sir and it has been really
insightful to hear your thoughts with
your experiences and how they you know
on the impact and effective user AI it's
great to understand the you know
specific parts around the data analytics
as well we look forward to seeing how AI
will continue to shape the world around
us and hope our viewers will be inspired
to embrace its potential and the
opportunities we have a lot more you
know we do a cast coming up as well and
look at the you know playlist We already
publish a few and we'll be releasing
more interesting discussions like we
have done with children today thank you
very much
thank you filing foreign
[Music]